[Music]
New York comic-con
welcome to Marvel contest of Champions
summoner showdown finals every week for
nine weeks three contestants have come
to the Marvel offices here in New York
City and competed in specially crafted
challenges for a chance to advance to
the finals right here with you at New
York Comic Con they faced an
unpredictable Deadpool with the ability
to switch healthbox
they had to survive three whole minutes
with an unstoppable war machine and many
had the almost impossible task of trying
to take down the mighty maestro but the
challenges of summoners showdown were
just half the battle the other half was
who you picked and how you use them we
were not disappointed good god we
witnessed some savvy play and masterful
use of legendary characters like
Wolverine Doctor Strange
Human Torch iron hearts were broken but
that last bit maestra was just like no I
made one small mistake and in this game
that can be everything secret identities
were revealed this is the first time I
think anybody's saying invincible yeah
videos are centered around silence and
just show up skill rivalries were
reignited legacy heading to New York
Comic Con take on his friend heat once
again yes and he called me out on the
last house that's awesome he's good
friends I look forward to facing it and
sage advice was just straight-up ignored
come on seriously Diablo was the dude
could have done better if you chose
Diablo no regardless we've made it to
the finals with the best of the best and
had plenty of fun along the way today we
have our nine summoners facing two new
challenges the stage is set are you
ready for a showdown New York Comic Con
let us hear you are you ready well then
get hyped because we're about to crown
our winner for the 2019 morph contest of
Champions summoner showed us give it
oh my god it is the showdown finals baby
nine weeks 27 summoners narrowed down to
nine
I'm Josh slay this is ripen Argos aka
ancient comma God oh my gosh I were here
yeah we've made it exciting it's
exciting here we are we could not do it
without these two gentlemen now in my
last legs and belted in dorky Diggity
damn yeah oh my goodness
I'm really ready I'm ready I'm so ready
for this I was I couldn't get a wink of
sleep last night got no sleep I been
good sleep last time all right well we
got a big big finals right here should
we introduce what they're who they're
playing against I think so
is it time I think I know who they're
competing against let's find this
challenge oh let's find out this
challenge all right let's hear it Dave
well you guys know the way that I say
this champions names very well it's hi
[Music]
Danny
Oh Marion is in the house he's got a
hundred percent champion boost a hundred
percent attacking health three hundred
percent health boost and improved power
gain now for those of you that know
Hyperion you know that he's already got
power gain and it's now being improved
so you guys got to be smart you got to
pick the right champion to keep that
power in place I like it all right Dave
I got to ask you what's going on what
kind of champions are our summoners
looking to pick to take on Hyperion you
got a head vibrato on n hi
it is organized by the end of this okay
best believe absolutely so what we're
looking for is either a power draining
champion or a power locking champion
I would suggest go power lock or go for
a nullifying champion I don't know maybe
could be Doc Ock or could be sim supreme
or Doc strange or Hawkeye or Sparky
I don't know pick any one of those or
maybe not they usually don't pick who I
see the same people don't seem to listen
to our ki diggity Dave and it's led to
their downfall so uh guys I think this
this challenge it's gonna be nuts and
I'm ready to see you can do it and we're
gonna see who can beat high in the
fastest time you're gonna get three
minutes fast ko time wins yeah real
quick I want to give a little bit of
info if you don't know who hi beard is
his name is Marcus Milton he's a very
super very super man like a very a man
who's very super and he's from another
planet brought to earth he's gonna be a
tough one for our summoners sweet bring
out our summoner I mean we gotta bring
them out we can't have a showdown
without summoners all out at once let's
have all of our summoners come onstage
we've got laga see ya what order are you
in come on we gave your order
my goodness laga CDT melodic metal miss
Antonio panda man Pete vincible eats
roasted bagel chunky be big blue 8:07
whoo all right guys you have all of
these fans watching you to see if you
will win all right we're gonna go one by
one you're gonna cheer to who you think
is gonna take on the prize
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
alright that's pretty good so you might
be a little ooh first of all let's give
it up for the nine finalists they have
narrowed it down from 27 you have made
it on this stage live to compete right
here in the mold with the New York Comic
Con but first Ryan I'm gonna hold up
these trophies you want to talk about
them a little bit sure what there's
getting no I want to get these guys off
I want to do some competitions new
competition get off of my stage you guys
Wow there's one hold on one thing the
final or the six people that will not be
making it they will be winning a tiny
mug for their tiny tears so one thing
that I love to do is go tiny mug for
your tight all right guys you hear that
good perfect we know that this is also
the trophy I just wanna show it to them
cuz gorgeous
be careful Josh it is heavy right all
right we can get him on stage now all
right gentlemen lady please off stage
alright y'all give it up the summoner's
whoo
feeling good you guys ready to see some
action
alright we're ready to do this race I
just want to make sure that when you
come on stage summoners and you sit on
this seat you have 30 seconds to choose
your character there will be a time
limit started so make sure you know who
you want to choose
well they 30 seconds 30 seconds make it
happen make it work all right I would
like to bring up our first competitor
here we go our first Summoner legacy
I guess II feel good all right nice
height video take your seat takers
coming to us from Canada
you beat maestro in one minute nine
seconds don't start yet I'm gonna tell
you in the thirty seconds go on the
clock
we got people with clocks over there you
just injure shirts they're resetting the
clock you're gonna thirty seconds
starting now
pick your summer okay doggy diggity Dave
he has to pick his so you've given some
recommendations gave some
recommendations and there is something
very important is that hyperion does
have limo who Keith does help limber so
you got to make sure that you are
sidestepping like an Iraqi took it Oh
Jose he already chose what okay we got
to count you down when you're ready all
right cuz we gotta do the whole three to
one thing okay you just read here so
reading alright so everything I think I
got ten seconds left
okay so druggy do you have in oh wait
six five four three two one
okay turkey DVD Dave he would go and
talk I was hired PD on break it down
first and so he's going to go in
he can't have too many berries but it's
great with Doc Ock because he has a
great reach he can sidestep like crazy
now you'll see once he starts getting
those attacks in he's gonna start power
locking him you can see that right up at
the top of that red icon right there
he's got a power lock so he can now
attack without giving him any power and
he's actually power draining him at the
same time so as long as he can play this
little dance he's gonna he's gonna match
this he's gonna get it he's gonna get it
right now remembers a fastest ko timer
idiot two minutes coming down here we go
whoo but he has pushed him over into an
sp3 we're going to take some damn you
early that's not going to take him out
he's gonna be fine he still take this
out he's gonna be looking for the whist
is amol whoo flex it on him unbelievable
all right down to 32% [ __ ] is you're
right that Reach is really paying
dividends but all right you got it
absolutely he's got himself an sp2 you
just go ahead and launch that oh he's
got an sp3 now he can just as soon as he
power locks him he goes ahead and
launches it yes here we go get that
damage perfect bonus amazing I love the
adjusting shake I'm a pieces of my
period today boy I have here but hi back
in a big way down to 7% he did a couple
hits a that was a major energy right
there he's going in with the sp1 still
has him power locked as long as he can
sidestepping he's gonna be just fine
with it oh all right there you go we are
still in the same but still be in a
minute 20 left
7% held left for as you can see that
power lock girl really helping him out
fighting hard Kofi to top round solutely
he's gonna have to play some serious
instinct here we go let's such lists hey
Doc got going to the top rope again he's
gonna Daisy
getting it in I learned
[Music]
wearing out high period in the corner
feed the great 45 43 seconds left now
Davey's burning through time if now we
get through all this time that he's
going it looks like he's going to get
the win he's got him locked into a
backdraft intercept such a nice year
they're going on right now he's gonna
keep on doing that London SP 1 over 27
seconds peat is powerless to settle down
they don't see it is there anything to
do more games he has 18 coming up about
15 seconds left with Haiti and at 20%
he's gonna have to launch that SP -
that's gonna give him some extra damage
[Applause]
[Music]
two minutes 55 seconds you want to talk
about down to the wire guys talk to a
boy what's going on how we feeling over
there okay yeah we came over your second
question you the last second what was
going through your mind I just try to go
as fast as I can had a bit of a rough
start had to really print those
intercepts all right give it up for live
you see one more time we will see if he
moves on we will see if he moves on oh
all right goodness right who we got next
huh up next is DT melodic metal come on
up come on up coming to us from Las
Vegas was our week three winner beat the
war machine challenge using a Wolverine
you remember 30 seconds when we tell you
three two one 36 on the clock go ahead
and choose your character so let's break
that while he's choosing his character
laughs as he did it two minutes 55 yeah
what did he use the strategies well how
did it work so we said well yeah
basically he went in with Doc Ock which
has a power lock mechanic built in which
means that Hyperion with all that power
gain is not power gaining at all that
large Rita from Doc Ock allows him to
have easy intercepts he's able to hit
him from far away and he kept him locked
in the corner already we got man we're
gonna hit that begin quest for me you
can get in there and we'll count you
down get in there yes all right are you
guys ready to see the tectonic medal all
right let's do it
three two one all right dirty Dicky damn
here we got magic versus hype Adi
magic the character to go with maybe
well magic has a nullifier on her sp1 so
she can stop his power gaining but she
can't stop him from power gaining from
regular hits so he's gonna have to build
up to an sp2 if Hyperion builds up to
his sp3 to fast as he just did he's
gonna eat it oh so he's got to survive
this use his SP to lock him in and
hopefully get that backdraft intercept
loop going on in the corner nice that
was the - hitman you said you don't want
to take hits it was gonna be one of
those games in and out and dodging and
trying to get absolute larry's him so
he's gonna push him into the corner he's
got his SP - he got in he got in that
that bait ring there any power locked
him so he's gonna push him into the
corner as long as he can keep that going
he's gonna be in good shape here we go
alright again rember the time to be 255
down to 2 minutes coming up on two
minutes 10 my period several percent
magic sitting pretty at 56% here we go
try this loop right here see if he can
keep on doing it back off see if he'll
follow it and I was following right now
he's gonna add in another SP - magic on
following assumption tock keeping him in
that corner backing him up and started
that illusion talk about that combo of
it to be CP low take us a minute so
that's what's called a backdraft
intercept so you do a couple of hits you
back off the AI will follow you and you
intercept and push them back in the
corner and continue on with the power
lock nice so he cannot take another hit
if he takes another combo looks like
he's going to go down that's true just
about to get a special one for magic oh
where do five percent minute 21 on the
clock this is a bad spot spam but he's
still got that combo off again down
hyperion down to berry and he's got it
maybe 50%
he's gonna dump that teen and he's got
magic
is that going to bed you can set the bar
below what's he gonna do here we go
Wow what's the time what's the time
what's the time you minutes Wow all
right you were at 1% for a good matter
that match did you think you're gonna
pull out at no you heard it here folks
you heard it here oh my goodness I
thought would help guys give it up for
DT melodic meadow the bar has been moved
my friend the bar has been has been
moved my gosh just knock out legacy I
know it looks like it it looks like it
so Georgie why was magic how did magic
fare better than Doc Ock in that match
so magic will go in and do an RSP 2 if
as long as you can land it before he
gets the SP 3 he did get that he
survived and he was able to lock him in
the corner by doing backdraft intercepts
now every so often he may not follow and
that's where he takes some combo damage
which you saw he was taking a lot of
hits there so she is a good option but I
still think Doc Ock is the safer option
to get the win
nice I listen right up next is Miss
insomnia misses here we go
join us sit on the floor Susan strategy
hold on
when we I will tell you what once you're
settled she's making herself comfortable
she likes she likes a good comfortable
all right 30 seconds start now
all right 30 seconds are on all right so
we saw magic we saw dr. Hawk who do you
want to see compete
I saw magic [ __ ] I still love sim
supreme for this no your buyers are
great for this Oh more magic she's
running listen Sammy on three two one
all right it's more magic at hi beauty
uh there we go so she got in her first
parry that's to build up her own power
meter she cannot use too many of those
at some point the limber is going to
kick in and you're gonna be taking some
combo damage from that point
so she's just fighting her time it looks
like he's building up to sp3 but it
looks like after we saw a deep sea
melodic metal you can take the damage
get to your sp2 and lock in the corner
and hopefully get that back draft
intercept loop going on oh that's so job
such a great animation alright take your
time like you saw coming in with that
call very good no no take it some damage
oh nice a little bit late on that SP too
and he was able to block it so she's got
to build up another one unfortunately he
had three yeah no we're gonna see if
that ends before he comes out sitting
pretty 10% damage business huh me has a
regard oh yeah that's sadly that will
[Music]
still move on yes guys this insomnia
more time remember this insomnia was one
of the nine best summoners we've had in
the show down here miss insomnia tough
tough tough tough so what were some of
the pitfalls day that we so as you can
see magic is a very particular character
you've got to get to that sp2 you cannot
take damage which is why going with a
nullifier like a sim supreme or going
with Doc Ock is such a safe option
because you stop the power gain right
away you don't even have to deal with
that yeah so if you get the right pull
the right AI
and the right RNG then you can win it
you guys are the next one I'm realm
where until it feels good all right up
next is pad and a man
and impede our week 5 winner in the
Deadpool challenge coming to us from
Seattle alright Penniman please the
jacket looking great 30 seconds begin
stop talking you ready
30 seconds begins now all right so what
character might we see nicely some more
bad supreme breakdown white 7 supreme is
one of your picks
so some supreme as a natural nullifying
ability so as soon as the opponent has a
buff he just nullifies it right away and
he has a fantastic fleet as soon as he
builds up to an sp3 on his and he starts
attacking the health just melts off
amazing so it may be a speed play sim
supreme vs high here we go now one of
the great things about sim supreme is
that he's constantly gaining power as
you can see but he does not gain power
off of attacks interesting so at some
point he's going to build up that sp3
after he finishes his power cycle up
there and he's just getting in the right
hits on on Hyperion right now
fortunately the nullified did not kick
in now he has to deal now he didn't take
very much damage now no she had an armor
up buff going on there so as you can see
that's that icon all the way in the far
left so that was that's how he was able
to mitigate that damage that Oh as soon
as he gets into that sp3 he's going to
be in some good and a good range very
okay it'll be just gets him some bleed
coming off of sim supreme
oh no arch obsidian was not on his side
it did not nullify a lot
Hyperion looking to claim another
southerner
and sadly panda man Pete what's long
before I period give it up for panda man
for payment Peter heartbreaks aplenty
here at but again I'm at our showdown
finals Hyperion is brutal this is brutal
I can't be elite Elite 9 yeah Ryan we
got another summoner Lewis finish doing
his little business over here so Simeon
supreme runs on RNG which is random
number generator so it may or may not
work but most of the time it works so if
you go up against Hyperion he pulls up a
power gain buff he just nullifies it
right away
and when you parry with sim supreme you
also pull up a nullifier and as you
attack you're supposed to pull up a null
afire just wasn't it just wasn't broken
but we've got another summoner
invincible coming to us from California
only hit twice in his match that got him
here to the finals
clean clean up that screen make sure
it's nice leaving it up you got you
ready
30 seconds begins now okay Derby Diggy
Dave we've seen two of your picks I have
seen them and you know I think I think
I'm principals probably going to go for
Doc strange which is the un-- symbiote
sized version of sim supreme or he may
go with sim supreme I'm not I'm not sure
adjustments last manager who interesting
is he going we can't we can't forget
they win tidy mugs for their time with
magic all right we see the same
summoners you the same champions and
kind of like I admit they're Strads
basement kind of like what they've seen
before all right we got magic what
you'll see with here we go we got into
the match okay good
are we good well you ready all right
three two one all right we're back with
more magic now invincible has a mastery
of the game in a way that he can see
when decide step went to attack yes and
he's going to be able to get a lot of
those intercepts he was able to bait and
look as when it helped him push into
that SP - mm-hmm yeah we saw that we
said only two hits when he played his
doctor strange on the stubbornest
showdown there you go - you've got a
great now this is the interesting part
because depending on what kind of AI
profile you're going up against they may
bait a lot or they may just hold on to
it I'm just launch an sp3 and it looks
like he happened to get a very
aggressive AI this hydrogen went to
allow him to take command of this match
and with the AI aggressive AI since with
this great command of how to - in and
out and his Moke movement on the screen
that helps him out right absolutely so
as you can see he's got his SP - right
there and he was able to power steel
with that SP Baron you're going to build
right into the SP - once again it took a
couple of hits their hands but still
good at 85% health two minutes on the
clock
warthog Aryan
for the parent he's going for the SP -
what he's doing it here we go ohh
Hyperion coming back in a big way
clutch intercept right there in here
almost got to the SP Perry went in to
the motor so he wasn't able to
capitalize on that but he's going back
in he baited out that heavy attack
watch him to minute 35 left here we go
another clutch intercept into the SP -
we got ourselves a showdown
one minute once again ladies and
gentlemen the bar has good news he's a
fan akiza Fanning my goodness that's
three people three summoners have made
in summoners will we see more I think we
will once Louise is finished tallying
the score Louise got this cute cute you
coming to us from Milwaukee Wisconsin
using dr. strange in the war machine
challenges how he got here all right put
30 seconds on the clock for you you
ready chose he's a hit he's going with
magic here I got it
he got it Ben he doesn't need your 30
seconds I can use it I can get some
water in those thirty Seconds to Mars in
three two one okay so again we're seeing
the same thing so how will he eats play
style influence how magic does this
round so Y it is he also understands the
concept of instinctive such so he's
going to use side steps to try to get in
on him now depending on whether he can
get Hyperion to bait which he just did
and build up to that SP two is really
going to decide as how this match goes
it goes any Bates out that SP where goes
gets the five hit combo gets the sp2 and
get hurt go drain and the power/lock
he's not building those on any strangers
back order it's gonna go for a backdrop
intercept hi Biron doesn't take it but
he does give him a heavy attack which
gives him another in and it goes in gets
that sp1 faded you're going in for that
SP - right um - me - yeah now it looks
like Hyperion's not all that aggressive
on this one gab is baiting quite nicely
now will the AI change in mid match ways
are gonna stay aggressive her who's
gonna go back and forth no once you get
it once you get an aggressive AI it
stays aggressive so right here you just
got another SP to eat is staying right
there at a very healthy 99% en and
already got Hyperion down to 35 5% got
another powering on going hard here we
go get him in that corner pouring it on
putting the boots to him unbelievable
power drain to do pushing down to 60%
and he got in an extra hit got the
nice here here we go 29 1 bumped off
legacy it might be the case oh my gosh
we got some nude like Movers & Shakers
this is insane this is literally insane
we're seeing the best of the best
I'm sorry - the rest of the livestream
team I'm losing my voice up here because
we got roasted bagel
[Applause]
roasted bagel is our week for winner in
the maestro challenge used spider-gwen
you guys ready we're gonna put 30
seconds on the clock for you did you
have a bagel this morning I did not now
no bagel does that mean what it means
nothing
oh we're good all rockin that's the
popular one today are you ready all
right in three two one
[Applause]
okay more get matching in the hi Peter
yard going round per round
we got another set here so if he loses
win if he does win he's got to do it
faster or with more help exactly on this
point he's trying to get him to bait it
looks like he's not baiting he's got the
sp3 and this is this is part of that
this is part of the risk of going with
magic if you get the right AI and you've
got the right mastery of the character
you can do real well but at this point
he's already taken a good amount of
damage he's down to 59% so he's really
got to be on his a game to finish this
out to get a faster time there's debate
and get it done boom blox in the SP -
got a thoraseal yeah and now he's just
got to get him in the corner he baits
out a heavy he gets another in and he's
going in for that he's not going to get
the SB to yet so he's got to get another
back trap intercept but he does get to
meet which do another in two minutes on
the clock it's it's crunch time he's
already under two minutes he has to be
this [ __ ] oh it took that's a hard row
and the power chair and that done is it
cuz he didn't go legal this morning
salmon bagel was roasted indeed for
roasted Baker
yeah no mercy from hype here
24 is still the time to be by invincible
weapon a 24 is the bar 24 oh my goodness
whoo all right up next we have junkie if
you remember Chuck TB was our week 1
winner on the Deadpool challenge yep
kick this whole thing off all right Finn
a little while since we saw you chunky
yeah let's get this clock going 30
seconds on the clock begins now I want
to see a new champion oh yeah it seems
like it seems like a huge gamble to go
with how the AI might behave absolutely
it's it's it's high-risk high-reward
going with magic but if you get the
wrong match your it's just not a good
look
oh no yeah I can't bit me and that's
nothing like the summer showed and this
is important this is crazy I think we're
ready to get it's not ready 9 man what's
gonna drag this out oh yeah take me
three minutes go ahead and go into that
quest all right guys here we go in three
oh it's the magic gamble going on in
magic gamble I like it the magic gamble
oh very aggressive AI yeah oh my so what
we want to see here is him get over to
his sp2 world having Hyperion launch
something on him so he went in to try to
block him he ended up getting
intercepted with a special but this AI
does seem to be fading very well look at
that power to him look at his life early
on that's 28% two minutes yeah but he is
getting the fates which is very very
important as soon as bagel is able to
get a bagel sorry as soon as chunky
piece is able to get over to the sp2
version we can start the business now
this is so many 7s now the whole what
I'm realizing is everyone's kind of do
the same thing when you talk about like
that
yeah bats rats intercept so what kind of
what the AI is the AI doing anything
that's gonna be tricking them that's
gonna try to get like the AI trying to
bait them in any way shape or form
yes
every so often instead of just following
whenever the whatever the player is
backing off the AI may not follow they
intercept you so in give it yes ooh oh I
mean the magic play can be anyone's game
a magic gamble that's the magic of magic
damn magic gonna make a child can you
step up and play the magic gamble I I
think we're down to our last of the nine
one more one more they need to I think
get less than two minutes yeah two
minutes is the time they need to beat to
move on to the final round all right
8:07 please come on up to the zero seven
you know nice shirt I like the Sherman
for everybody here at New York Comic Con
big blue is a New Yorker let's hear it
for me
[Applause]
30 seconds on the clock list you're
gonna you know you know you alright ii
see it many times put it down don't
imagine i like our final summoners like
let's get it in you've seen a lot of
magic we gonna see more magic all right
you guys are gonna do the three two one
because i'm losing very good alright
y'all y'all ready to get it done our
final summoner right
three two one you gotta wait till the
good wait why that's right that's what
three two one fine I can't do as well as
you Josh
alright here we go magic words hi may
the AI be with you my friend alright so
as you can see he is built up to two and
a half years and he's got the power gain
and he gets right into the sp3 he's
gonna take a little bit of damage but he
can still finish this off back story yes
so as long as he can get to that to lock
in the corner and get that backdraft
intercept off the ground he's gonna be
in good shape now again tough time to be
because in order to get into that top
figures again these summers new drill
down to the top three absolutely so
we've got his sp2 up and which did give
him some power gain because he did power
steal right here he went for oh here we
go pouring on he went for a backdraft
intercept he's not following but he's
still able to connect locked him in the
corner off that power lot yeah blowing
off his strikes but he's taking a lot of
damage oh no that's a lot of damn
percent hell there is no he'll block
he'll going he's got he'll block there
so he cannot recover that damage
intercepts were not working out with him
today with the magic that is the magic
gamble and I was not with him give it up
one more time
oh my goodness
guys we have our final three I think we
just lost 15 pounds running back and
forth hey guys
are you ready to see the final three
compete for the coveted trophy and
bragging rights and titles but wait what
do we what are they winning what are
they winning what do they win what do
they win right what do they win all
right this guy this beautiful trophy do
you honor it you want to raise it up
always gonna raise it up it's heavy
yeah yeah yeah you know the final grand
prize winner going home with this trophy
it lights up by the way a 6 star
featured hero crystal an exclusive
in-game title huge bragging rights and
second a third also go home with some
prizes you're gonna have you gentlemen
hold for us third place goes home with a
medal there you go a very nice smell -
and second place goes home with a silver
medal as it is in sports yes correct
gentlemen we just saw nine incredible
battles break down what we saw the
trends there who we were seeing we saw a
lot of magic a lot of magic do you think
magic was the right way to go we saw Doc
Ock fare very well at the beginning Doc
Ock does fare very well and he does do a
lot of damage it was just a little bit
of trouble at the beginning of the match
so if that match kind of went into a
little bit of a longer status there but
as you can see magic is very volatile as
a use for a champion because you can
either do real well and just kind of
ride the wave if you've got the right AI
but if not if you got if you got a
really passive ai he's just gonna power
gain and take you down as you saw no
Diablo sadly Diablos in all of our
hearts okay if you were to play would
you go magic cluster no I would go with
Doc Ock why not go mad because my
playstyle
I love sidestepping which is where you
you - out of the way up there - and then
you're able to counter without having to
get a parry because you have limber and
he was the safest option
had all the lock down had the damage he
had all the goods
like dancing it is absolutely like a
little bit I got nobody footwork
footwork spatial awareness that's right
it's got a little bit of the ollie going
on there and there little rope-a-dope so
what were the what other champions could
they abuse that you thought would have
fared well other champions you can use
this is also a very high-risk champion
was using a stark Spidey which would
give you a taunt ability and that gives
you a higher chance for the AI to launch
their specials he also has a power drain
mechanic but he just does so much damage
he would be great for a speed play Hood
has a nullifying ability just on his
basic attacks which would keep those
power gains from from hopping on however
that's also rng base so it may or may
not happen so for me doc ock was the
best choice in terms of locking it down
and making sure that happens great no
sorry no I was gonna say since the AI is
such a big gamble right
are there any champions you picked I can
kind of negate that that no matter
what's going out with the AI no matter
what's gonna with it the RNG they still
have a chance to be they still have a
chance to overcome that yes so that
would be that would be doc ock this is
what you're going against is not so much
the AI but you're going against what the
AI has in their notes which was enhanced
power gain and Hyperion Hyperion already
having power gain you want to stop that
before it has a chance to build up like
it oh no I don't know man these these
we're gonna find out on top three very
very soon there's going to be another
challenge there will be there will be
our officials are conferring we have the
New York State Athletic Commission we do
not hear three right you won't see the
official three summoners left in this
challenge let's do it y'all alright
gentlemen we're gonna bring you on stage
we're gonna ask you to stand Center and
we're gonna get to talk to you a little
bit let's bring up invincible with a
time of 1 minute and 24
[Music]
yeet with one minute and 29 seconds
and DT melodic metal with two minutes
come on down don't be afraid guys come
right down girl come on closer come
closer your friends your buds come
closer closer
all right gentlemen you've made it one
step back there we go all right you made
it this far what is going through your
mind because you don't know what the
challenge is you don't know anything
what's going through your mind right
what's the challenge it's a good answer
you want me to tell you the challenge
not gonna tell you we're gonna make you
wait Jeep it's kind of waiting to see
what it is right all right it's just for
t-rex but do you okay also talk about
shoutouts do you guys have any Alliance
shoutouts family friends shoutouts you
wanna do yeah to all my family and
friends that helped me actually get
ready for this it was a big reveal and I
had some advice from a lot of people
they helped me practice actually so
thanks a lot
I don't want to give names out because I
forget someone so you know it's like an
Oscar winning all right yes watch out
the entire MC community because it's
it's pretty crazy that everyone's here
it's awesome shout to the entire Omni
house I broke catcher boom in my boys
Eddie G and D show from the 78 backwoods
I love it I love it yeah shout outs to
family and friends for low key 10k chat
and also Marvel Latino chat esta all
right we have to do the official touch
the trophy once that's nice you can win
these guys josh is so strong that thing
weighs like 20 pounds 10 to 15 pipe you
up - uncle it's 35 all right so in this
bag we see your names inside they're
random we will determine to see who goes
first in this challenge three crystals
three crystals with the numbers on them
okay this sign magic grabs an infinite
bag of infiniteness if you pull your
hand out and you don't have a hand
laughs don't look at us yeah that's not
our fault all right pull out one drum
roll rolled and another key to he's
going second
no let's make it official
hopefully like he likes it it's sports
man it's competition number you still
looked at it though that's cute
all right this is our order so who wants
to announce the challenge whoo-hoo once
I have that honor I would take it it
Dave you got this I got this man I gotta
break it down guys here we go you guys
have made it this far as you know you
get through Act four you beat maestro
we're not doing that again
you get to act five and you get a
certain title when you get to act five
you're true can you tell me what that is
you're gonna be fighting the coal letter
which I call the Pina cool if you like
being 100% champion boost 100% attack
and held 100% health boost again he'll
blocks that you cannot use a healing
champion you try to survive this the
special three is active you're gonna be
turned into that crystal if you don't if
you are not careful and as you know his
specials are almost not fully available
you got to know the exact right cadence
on block - block - all that good stuff
you guys know what you're doing this is
gonna be interesting
you know the collector is one of the
elders of the Marvel Universe the last
of his race and he likes to collect
things it's really it's the name fits
he likes to save people gentlemen come
on down come on down now that you know
what the challenge is I love how we're
moving you around to different parts the
stage you know all right now without
giving anything away now that you know
the challenge what are you feeling I'm
wondering if he has the same notes he
has an act 5 do we have that answer as
that giveaway the same knows of 5.2 it's
not they're not unblockable
85% 60% 40% 20 but he does have some
ability accuracy reduction so you got to
be careful with that you can't just go
in and quake them to death so that's not
that's not going to work for you Oh
youth I was trying to stay alive can I
say live words to live by man man was
many words many words good nerd yeah I'm
ready you said less words than you need
I'm sorry yeah Oh what is this what is
this what is this we were watching some
playthrough of this earlier before the
doors open
it's nasty you guys this is gonna be
brutal it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
good it's gonna be crazy I think we're
ready to do this
gentlemen can you please move out the
stage except for the player one player
one stay on stage you need to set the
bar high that trophy
could be yours you have defeated laga
see I know your friends I know it's a
great community but you know you
defeated them I mean just like IBM
Vincent DC which are sucres players so
I'm trying my best on your best it's
very nice such a polite boy my boy
raised right okay we're gonna make a
spider boy it's feelings still got some
time ten seconds remaining we could give
them a little bit more time by the time
this is a goal challenge we'll give it a
45 minute yeah dang 30 seconds left
man give me another 30 seconds so don't
be a kid eh what kind of champions are
we looking to deal with the collector
sepia collector actually is he's an
equal opportunity but Wooper all right
it doesn't really matter who you pick
wooing is he can just knock down any one
however I do have some suggestions ago
champions that have a long - we'll help
you - Dex those specials that are very
difficult - Dex but you do want to try
to do as much damage as possible because
I'm not sure anyone is actually going to
beat them ooh
the protection is durga DDM says no
one's gonna beat to the Nocona well
what's the audience's behind his back
yi-yi-yi-yi-yi
yi-yi-yi-yi-yi I'm just trying to get
I'm just trying to get Ryan to say you
eat this entire time he has yet to say
it I think in all of our weeks all right
I think he's ready they were living it's
there's a lot of action it's loading all
the collectors collection he's like
pulling all's knickknacks out all them
up put my baubles over here Kwanzaa here
probably has cosmo the space dog hanging
out Lewis tells us it's fine it's gonna
work great everybody give it up for
Louise Louise so we do have a few things
to watch out here yeah now a lot of
people go in for apari right away he
does have tenacity which means that he
may just shrug it off instantly which
can catch people off-guard and you end
up taking a combo piece to the face
now that tenacity is there any
conditions that there that are always
gonna set that up or is that gonna be a
rant and it's completely random so you
might get one where it doesn't work at
all more you might get one where it
works every single time and you kind of
can't rely on that however he does have
a short hit on his - makes it a little
more difficult to sidestep him and
attack him so I would suggest if you are
having trouble with that run over to the
wall and use a bank which is Dec sitting
on the wall and returning attack this
way you're not going too far away where
you can't reconnect just hit the ATM and
say what kind of champions have that a
great - that you were talking about that
can really cover that ground so long -
champions are venom has a very long -
but he also has a very long reach as
well he has a lot of damage he can bleed
him out because he the collector is not
bleed immune it's also not poison immune
so you can bring in a damage overtime
champion and do very well as well you
probably believe want to have some power
control if you are not used to taxing
some of his specials and at the same
time another - champion I like a lot is
dark Hawk he has a very very long -
it'll help you to - out of the way of
those very very difficult specials now
we have a lot of members of the MC OC
community here so for those who are
maybe new to the game they're watching
this on Marvel Live and there they want
to get into the become a summoner
themselves what are some of the skills
they want to learn first
this one's tough yeah this one is tough
you got to be on your game you got to be
able to get the parry but be able to see
if he's going to use tenacity or not so
you'll want to parry and wait just a
small moment to see if you have the
opening if that is going to be the way
that you're going outside of
sidestepping or trying to intercept are
you ready
it looks like we have are you ready the
ever-lovin blue-eyed three hold on one
second oh we got the thing up here I
want to hear a really good it's
clobberin time and I need some help with
that John Seely yeah can you give me a
nice Ben Grimm esque
it's clobberin time I think so it's
clobberin time
yeah to see the beginning of the final
three will count off with me in three
two one
fine it's the ever-lovin blue-eyed thing
let's see BCA Yancy Street burrito today
ladies and gentlemen let's go so break
down the thing why is the thing a good
choice bad choice well the thing is go
he's building up some rock stacks right
now which is going to help him with with
that damage when he is ready to go and
if he does end up taking damage he's
going to build up some fury stacks
that's good really gonna help him lay
the hurtin down so as you can see he's
parrying and he's waiting just a moment
to make sure that he has a safe opening
now that sp1 is if he happens to launch
that that's gonna be very difficult he
good strategy form he blocked the entire
thing you can dex it but right now if
you haven't practiced it it's playing
the same card at this point so he didn't
bring up those rocks tax he was able to
kind of mitigate some of that damage so
he can do more of that the lower his
health gets though and the more of those
furious that he gains up exactly see the
orange yes now the 140 he's gonna be
wearing amount of damage with that but
he did not get lucky on the crit if he
crit that would have been a great amount
of damage no he's got a bait out that SB
two days might have sp1 the collector
the collector the Pina codex
so you beating out a heavy attack goes
on in he's gonna launch that SP to once
again hopefully he did not get it over
it it is just not going for him if that
does grit its really a lot of damage and
I'm feeling kind of bad watch yeah
because
here's the thing going down a minute 40
seconds against a speed challenge you
have three minutes that's one to beat
the collective with he's pouring on but
isn't doing a lot of damage what he's
put me and you to do more make more of a
dent in the collector yes
so you can irrigate one thing that we
didn't mention we should have mentioned
was if all three of them get kayoed
which they probably will in the first
round we're gonna see a rematch to see
all three of them again compete to see
all right so give it up for ye one more
time yeah eat hang out you may come back
up here okay so who is our next summoner
who's always number two yeah all right
DT a lot of GG melodic metal
take your seat take your seat all right
tt we're gonna we're gonna let you
choose you got a little bit of time
don't worry about it no stress so the
crazy thing about Pina Cole ekta is even
if you knew that you're fighting
Pina collected today you have to go
through a pretty crazy quest just to get
to them so practice is a little bit hard
here yeah cuz you have to go through so
much just he even gets him there's no
way to like jump to the cliff you just
go to collect or gonna be like I want to
fight absolutely well I mean I nicknamed
him the collector of items I went
through so it's very very difficult
again as you saw it's not easy to dex
out of the way you either got to just
take the block damage and keep on moving
and try to do as much damage as you can
however it is possible to dex if you
block at first and then Dex on the end
either you're the bank yeah you should
be able to make something happen case
then we got dr. voodoo actually so doc
in food we haven't heard him mentioned
is this a good choice dr. voodoo is good
he's got a great - and he also has a lot
of reach so he's he's very good for
intercepting and if he can stack on the
LOA's which is a damage list buff debuff
sorry he's gonna be able to convert that
into poison and have a large poison
stack that's gonna be doing damage over
time while he's attacking if he plays
his cards right and he lands the power
burn on the right combo with the SP -
every time he attacks he's gonna be also
doing damage while draining haha his
power so this is gonna be interesting to
see if he can actually land that so
there's a bunch of circumstance if he
sets with these circumstances right he
can pretty much drain the collector of
his power real quick absolutely so if he
can keep his power down he can probably
do a really good amount of damage but at
some point the collector is gonna have
his tenacity needs going to overtake
that ability accuracy and it may not
work moving forward another gamblers get
it done whoo all right I want to rewind
a little bit - there will not be a
rematch you got my challenges mixed up
so it's whoever does the most damage to
the collector that will be who will win
the grand prize are you ready yes
all right there we go he doesn't want
your nonsense Josh let's get this moving
three doxa who do whoa
all right bye manly not even waiting for
the countdown
jumping him before the bell rings he
would get that little great reach like
he talked about absolutely and he was
able to get that person who somebody
took a couple hits there now if people
if he gets over to that SP - which is
where he's working at or he's going to
have to get the right combo meter number
see it has to be either even or odd to
get a particular result so if he does it
on the even combo right there he gets
the power burn so every time he attacks
as you can see he's doing damage and
draining his morass the same time he
said try through that power meter low
but now here he has a special -
absolutely and it lasts a pretty long
time ooh now you have the heavy attack
he's just trying to do as much damage as
possible and he's getting really lucky
from that's an acid oh my god there's a
great job he's power burning him keeping
it going very good the pressure pressure
ah you got the back cutters
keep going drain him down a lenin back
until 11 percent for dr. buddha he
hasn't applied to get this done right he
does now he just needs to get a great
intercept at this point - yeah
gets the even attack and he's got the
power burning read him down as long as
he does not have a special he's going to
be in good shape and he can just keep
the pressure on he kept the yeah he's
going i special yeah that's amazing so
now he has a minute
tell member a minute 30 left got the
collector down to 68 68 percent sweat is
huge Yvonne you sweat but that puts him
in the lead less than 70 percent so you
have a chance to take home that trophy
wait where you gonna put it in your
house probably on Vince's desk oh all
right but we got another summoner one
more attacks is it
68% is the percentage to be can you do
it I think so
where are you psyching about Josh I'm
trying to get us a longer than three
words that he doesn't need to what did
you have for breakfast
I didn't have a breakfast do you eat
gosh I'll let the man some so we saw dr.
voodoo doctor voodoo did very very well
got a 60% absolutely and it looks like
he's saying doc Buddha as well very good
that's a very powerful move doing that
sp2 on an even combo now the thing is
you have to keep an eye on your combo
meter at the same time while
intercepting or while making sure you've
got your combos in order launching that
and then making sure you take advantage
of it by keeping the pressure on them
the pressure is very important because
you want to make sure he does not gain
and a special attack yeah and that power
bro is doing right here we go
all right we're gonna do three two one
resume because he didn't listen to me
the timer's going all the time is still
going okay yes he's got it Josh here we
go here we go just so you know just
cycled the AI from one that he wanted
someone that no you never know he may I
somebody just rolled on him that's
that's now dare we accept your apology
there we go you know what you're gonna
count the three two one fight now three
two one fight
oh here we are the final summoner in the
showdown doctor voodoo versus have on
the corner that's right man we've got
we've got some griot versus those of you
that know what that is alright so good
already got already born on him been
invincible govern the 97% remember
everyone if he gets too
below 68% that will put him in the lead
as Fuli and he knew exactly where to go
he's got the power burn active and he
did not get the tenacity so he's able to
go in and just put that pressure on now
notice that he didn't block check him
too much to give him the sp1
he baited out the heavy attack got him
back under and he's just gonna keep on
bringing that percent keeping him down
below he is he got a special one yeah
he's collecting all the collectors power
absolutely and that is some masterful
playing right there bringing him into
the corner got the SB to launched it on
the even attack power burn this
collector does not look like he's going
to be launching anything anytime soon
unbelievable yeah empty pockets I
believe keep controlling the parameters
so well
alright down to 27% again the collector
is getting down below 68 got that power
burn now as you can see one of the
really important things about having a
champion with such a far - is that
you're able to keep a little distance to
bait out a heavy attack without taking
damage we got down to 76 percent for the
collect their health more power burn
those are plush intercepts happening
right there this is what is keeping that
pressure on as you hear 60% that - back
is baiting out the heavy attack they're
done Simmons will have any room for
error
[Applause]
we have our summoner or Jamie
invincible give it up one more time for
invincible real strong
all right we need tally the scores we
gonna tell you the scores step right
here step right off off off please we're
moving this way hang out down there for
a minute all right so he tallies the
scores Dave I want to hear him in your
details about these strategies that we
saw of all the things they did not
expect to see today that was probably
number one on my list
he had such a mastery of the techniques
he would locked in not only the sb2 on
the on the even combo but he had the
lockdown
he had a mastery of this space which was
baiting out heavy attacks without taking
hits which is very difficult to do but
you really have to know how to space the
champion in order to do that and he was
he was landing those in spades and it
looks like he just got a bad recovery
there he backed off and the AI just took
him out happens that fast the collector
can strike that fast but hey everyone
give it up for all of our summoners long
road to get here why don't we bring up
all nine final summoners there was nine
weeks of amazing action in the Marvel
contest of Champions summoner showdown
let's give them their tiny mug for their
tiny there we go there we go there we go
Oh a little dinosaur okay come on down
come on down make room make room make
room Rex
[Music]
they're getting their little mugs tiny
mug so any mug so any mug tiny but in
these tiny bags are tiny mugs
okay for your tiny have we narrowed it
down to the final three so if I call
your name stay on this stage in third
place Yeats in 1 minute 27 seconds in
second place invincible one minute
one and DT melodic one minute in 28
seconds a little bit over here we're
gonna move off the stage this way he's
here three come on down coming down
coming down your three finalists for
Marvel contest of Champions seminar all
right you all get prizes you get prizes
you get prizes so yeet where's the
bronze what'd you do with the bronze do
you have what you wanted you wanna
presented sure I can Nexon it alright
need a third place third place goes to
Yeats yeah the middle when you got it
you got a crown I'm gonna put before
thee
well you can't stay in the front oh you
got to do it behind him so the camera
gets it is your first time proud of you
put it back over
[Music]
[Applause]
you gotta save a place
Langston you're gonna do this oh yeah
all right the second place goes to with
you to tell you to tie ribbon sights
high ribbon graduate and winner
oh the 2019 Model Contest a champion
summoner showdown finals
[Applause]
[Music]
tt please step forward for support we
should hire a winner is you let's get
let's get all three of you guys together
with all your medals all your trophies
like your prizes they're gonna take some
pictures and then we'll do it get some
final thoughts thoughts we've done nine
weeks you guys don't really feel
absolutely nice I mean I gotta say these
nine weeks I couldn't do it without Ryan
Penn a ghost bikes and Belkin dorky
advice of Belton dorky Dave Brian grants
are betray I'm draggin say oh yeah miss
all the people in the booth old people
Caban old people at marvel oh the fans
thank you
we're gonna get along some good photos
he kissed the trophy he kissed the
trophy I don't feel good about that
because I know Josh has touched the
trophy and I don't know where Josh is
bad no no no all right before you guys
move on ye how do you feel I feel all
right
I thought we're gonna go for a second
time that's why I'm kind of confused
yeah Josh got his his little bit back
and forth confused but you did great you
got here feeling real good I'm Vince all
right invincible second place how do you
feel not that great but you know read it
oh yeah I feel good about this but DT
man what he that was awesome there's a
lot of pressure on that seat so you know
while it wasn't what I what I was trying
to go for but you know it's good it's
good
also how
feel to be the crowned champion I don't
know how I wanted me so so now that you
chose your champion did you have any
second guessing like I don't know if I
chose the right one absolutely not you
were for sure yeah I used to do for
everything until I got like Corvis they
don't make it like everyone else in the
game I love it all right guys give it up
over time for your champion and final
three it's more to say it's more to say
oh yeah I just want to say that like
everything Kabam and Marvel have done
with this summer showdown thing it's
been one of the coolest experiences I've
had like since I can remember
so like thank you guys so much for
everything you've done the people here
are so cool so it's an awesome day thank
you thank you so much all right thank
you everybody thank you for watching ya
will contest the champion summoners
showdown finals and it has been
thrilling thank you everybody thank you
command and the command booth at five
five six check out marvel realm of
Champions if you haven't already pledged
your house play Marvel contest of
Champions there's a tournament going on
and we have it again here on stage
tomorrow so check that out guys nine
weeks is it I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna
miss you too I'm gonna see you introduce
this is Marvel your universe
[Applause]